numbers on the season for jake 20 games
19 starts six and seven even that out
today with a good game against the
seattle mariners 82 strikeouts 231 walks
a lot of those walks coming in those
first 15 starts where the command was a
little bit of an issue the lined up and
the one-nothing pitch the mid-swing and
a broken bad soft looper into shallow
left center field that's going to drop
in front of chaz mccormick for a base
hit mariner's first base runner of the
ball game
and seeger hits this out in the left
center field mccormick started in now
racing back and runs it down and left
center on the warning track back to
first base goes hannigar after the nice
running catch by mccormick the 1-2
defense swing and a miss a fastball up
and away france actually foul tipped it
into the glove of maldonado and he
angrily tosses his bat and helmet down
odor izzy works around the one out hit
and after a half inning mariner's
nothing astros coming up this will be
the third time he has faced the astros
in his last four starts he has had one
absolutely terrible start going four and
two thirds giving up nine earned runs
softly hit shallow center kelnick coming
on and he won't be able to make the play
it drops in front of him michael
brantley a little softer base hit into
center field two hole hitters for both
teams getting soft-serve base hits to
center field
deep left center field kel nick going
back to the warning track near the
garage doors with a leap in the air
kelnick makes the catch and that's going
to retire the side long fly ball by
alvarez but he's out number three order
izzy delivers
swing and a mess toro goes down on a
high fastball and that's the second
strikeout for jake one away he's got a
good gear to that four seamer so far
tonight
that ball popped into shallow center
field mccormick in correa out carlos
makes the call on the catch a one two
three frame for odor rizzy and we're
through one and a half both teams
they're number two hitters in the order
with singles to center field that's it
here's the ball swing on and hit off the
glove of correa the shortstop into
medium center field that thing was
crushed
should be a base hit that thing got on
correa and a heartbeat swaying and a
miss odor rizzy picks up a strikeout to
end the inning a strikeout every inning
for jake one hit one left on we head to
the bottom of the third scoreless
bottom of the third logan gilbert
looking good through two two two pitch
sliders swing on and miss struck him out
here in the third back-to-back
strikeouts 2-2 pitch to maldonado swing
and a miss and a nice slider strike
three on maldonado he's down and gilbert
has struck out class three hitters two
outs nobody on no score here's altuve
all right see what happens second time
through for the astros
altuve hooks one deep down the left
field line this ball is good home run
jose altuve
his first home run since july 30th and
the astros lead one to nothing a lot of
fun to watch this guy get hot down the
stretch
bradley drills one deep to right field
that ball will be off the wall brantley
takes a big turn but he hit it so hard
he'll be held to a single nice play by
haninger getting the ball back in
quickly bregman's the batter runner on
first base and two outs a little
momentum for houston here's the first
pitch to bregman bregman sends one into
right center field long run hannigar he
won't get there that's down and all the
way to the wall michael brantley on the
move he'll be waved around there will be
a relay throw that is late
astros take a two-nothing lead on the
rbi double by alex bregman
here's the wind-up and the 2-2 pitch
fastball swing and a miss by guriel for
strike three
so one away for the astros here in the
bottom of the fourth and a strike on
number four for logan gilbert one down
for houston payoff to correa
oh strike three call 96. lower inside
corner and correa a quiet exit
back-to-back strikeouts and he ropes one
to right field tucker on cue with
another line drive that'll be a two-out
base hit logan looks in has a sign for
murphy the stretch and the one-o pitch
swing and it's popped up foul on the
third base side seeger might have a
plate near the seats near the dugout
he's there he's got plenty of room and
he makes the catch and that's going to
retire the side and gilbert gets out of
trouble and the mariners now have
runners on its second and third with
nobody out here in the top of the fifth
inning
oh one pitch hit high in the air to
center field now drifting towards right
kyle tucker will have it tagging his
torrens but it's a bluff
not deep enough to score the row and
that's one out
that's popped up good call blubber
carlos correa calling off brantley
brantley wall
let carlos take the catch they both went
after it and brantley and carlos talking
about it afterwards that might have been
the idea i imagine between maldonado and
otorizzy is being able to locate that
fastball at the top part of the zone so
two on and two down and that'll bring up
jp crawford and now the mariners have to
have a clutch base hit line into the gap
in right center field terence is in
kelnick steam at home
jp crawford has tied this game up that
is such a big base hit michael brantley
on it third the go ahead run alex
bregman on it first base one out
into shallow left field racing in bowers
going out seeger seeger makes the over
the shoulder catch for the out and
there's two away in the inning
kyle seeger going way out there in
shallow left field along with crawford
bowers racing and couldn't get there two
on two away here's the set and the one
two on the way to guriel swinging it's
popped up
shallow right field coming in as mitch
hadiger he's there to make the catch and
that's going to retire the side and a
tremendous effort by anthony misevich
kyle seeger leads off here top six
this is pummeled out to right kyle
seeger leaving the yard and putting the
mariners in front number 34 for the
mariners third baseman and the mariners
have taken the lead with one swing in
the sixth inning the astros starting off
the bottom of the sixth inning they have
two on with nobody out looking for the
ground ball one one pitch swung off
popped up
playable seeger that's his voice you
hear makes the catch shoulder high
just to the left of the mound for out
number one double cloud get him out of
the inning 2-2 pitch to maldonado swing
and a miss struck him out worked inside
with a two-seam fastball and he swung
right over the top big k bottom six
pitch broken back ground ball to toro on
the third base side a second throws over
and plenty of time to get altuve and
casey sadler survives the six no runs
two hits nowhere is two left bottom of
the eighth inning diego castillo in the
game the wind-up and the pitch fastball
strike three called he gets correa
looking
with a fastball on the outside corner
one away for the astros here in the
bottom of the eighth
there's a ball hooked into left field
that'll be down for a hit trying to
bare-handed his bowers and he keeps it
in front of him as the lead miss diaz
with a pinch single to the left the
three to the myers slider strike three
called he got him looking on a front
door slider on the inside corner that
will retire the side the astros leave
the time run stranded at second base
what a pitch the merritt is looking to
head on here in the top of the ninth
inning
right back up the middle toro being
waved in toros steam at home here's a
throw he is in there standing safe
two-run mariners lead in the ninth
inning luis terence delivers seawall's
been outstanding nine and three eight
saves and eleven chances in the 2.39 era
in 48 games for the mariners now it's up
to bregman he represents the tying run
had an rbi double in the third singled
in the fifth
and bregman hits it high in the air and
deep to left field and you can kiss it
goodbye
off the community leader signs and we're
tied
8th homer of the season for bregman
first since june 9. how good did that
feel oh two to crawford
and that's lifted out in the right
center fairly deep racing back as tucker
leaves makes the catch crashes into the
wall
right in front of the astros bullpen
heck of a play by kyle tucker for the
second out the runner at second for the
astros is guriel correa is one for four
today
there's a ball under right field hit
well that'll be over the head of
hanukkah it'll bounce into the crowd and
that'll be a game-winner astros win it
five to four the walk-off double by
correa that is a big one coming back
against the seattle mariners that
bullpen has been so good